[Music]
[Applause]
All right. When I started open router
the beginning of 2023,
I had one major question in mind. I was
looking at this new market that was
coming online and and it was incredible.
Like at the very end of uh 2022, we all
saw chat GPT and I got bitten by the AI
bug. Um and I decided to look into
answering this question. Will this
market be winner take all? inference
might be the largest market ever in
software and this seemed like a critical
thing that everybody was assuming the
answer to the answer to it would be yes.
Um open AI was just far and away the
leading model. There were a few others
that were coming up on its tail and I I
built a couple prototypes to look into
what they could be used for and also
wanted to investigate open source. So in
this talk which Swix named um I'm going
to talk about the founding story of open
router and uh and go through a little
bit of the hoops that we jumped through
and sort of the investigation that we
did as we we put together this product
that started as an experiment and kind
of evolved into a marketplace over time.
In January,
we saw the first signs of people wanting
other types of models. And the the first
evidence was moderation. This this was
like a very clear interest from users in
looking for models where they could
understand why whether they'd be
deplatformed or what the the moderation
policy of the company was. And and we
saw some people like generating novels
where like it would be a detective story
and in chapter 4 um the detective would
find someone who like commits a murder
and shoots the victim and and opening at
the time sometimes refused to generate
that output or it was like questionably
against the terms of service. And of
course, we saw role play and and
basically a big gray area emerge around
what models were willing to generate.
So, uh, in and the next month, we saw
the open- source race begin. And that,
uh, I'm going to do a little bit of an
OG test here. Uh, raise your hand if you
ever used Balloon 176B.
There's a there's like 10 hands raised
um or opt by Facebook. This was like one
of the earliest open- source language
models about five hands raised. Uh there
were a couple of these emerging and
there were some very interesting
projects to help people access them and
uh and and early days they weren't
really useful for very much. So, uh, we
kept digging and, uh, and eventually
like the open source community, um,
round like ran into Meta's first launch,
which was Llama 1 in in February. And
Llama 1 in their abstract advertised
that it outperformed GPT3 on most
benchmarks. You can see the highlighted
part here, which blew everyone away.
This was huge. an open weights model
better than GBT3
and uh and especially a smaller model.
This was the 13 billion parameter
version, one that you could run on your
laptop um outperforming a large server
only like you know tons of money
required to run inference companies
model it and it was beating it on some
benchmarks. Everyone lost their minds
and Llama kicked off a huge storm. It
still was not very useful. I have to say
it was like a text completion model for
the most part and it was very difficult
to run locally. The infrastructure just
wasn't there. Um and people were
struggling to figure out what to do with
it which is when we found when we had
the greatest moment of all I think for
the birth of the long tale of language
models which was the first successful
distillation in March of 2023. Alpaca.
Uh, a group at Stanford took Llama 1,
generated a bunch of outputs on GPT3 and
fine-tuned Llama 1 on those outputs and
created Alpaca for less than $600 in to
like total. And this was an incredible
moment. It was the first time I saw the
transference of both style and knowledge
from a large model onto a small one. And
this me this was a huge unlock because
it meant that not only do you not need a
$10 million training budget to create
your own models, but you could also for
the first time make unique data
available as a service in the form of a
language model.
And
I immediately began to wonder like what
are there there's going to be tens of
thousands of these maybe hundreds of
thousands. Um and they seem incredibly
important. This is knowledge finally
being distilled into software. Uh there
needs to be a place on the internet to
discover these and understand what they
do because even this open weights model
was still closed in a way. It's a black
box. You get 7 billion floatingoint
numbers. You don't know what it's good
at or what to do with it. Very few
people used alpaca. Raise your hands if
you used alpaca.
I see about maybe 12. So it's like only
double the number of people who used the
like almost unusable open source models
on the previous slide.
So
open router initially started as a place
to collect all these things. Um but
before we got there I wanted to check
out people's willingness to bring their
own model to generic websites. Like what
if the developer didn't even know which
model a user wanted to use? How would a
user bring their choice of model to the
software that they want?
And uh in April, I launched window AI,
which was a an open- source Chrome
extension
that let a user choose their model and
let a web app just kind of suck it in.
And so you can see from the Chrome
extension here, if you look really
closely, um, this user is using
together's
open-source deployment of GPT next.
I can't I can't read it from here, but
like an open source model that um swaps
out OpenAI directly inside the web page.
So the next month, open router launched
and uh I uh co-ounded it with the
founder of the framework that that
window was built on, plasmo
um Lewis and we started open router
first a place to collect all the models
in one spot and and help people figure
out what to do with them. And it
eventually grew into a place that gives
you the like better prices, better
uptime, no subscription, and uh and the
most choice for figuring out which
intelligence your your uh software
should run.
So let's talk a little bit about what it
is because not everyone here might be
familiar with it. Um, we we have been
growing 10 to 100% month over month for
the last two years. It is an API that
lets you access all language models and
uh and it's also become kind of the
go-to place for data about who's using
which model um and how that is changing
over time, which you can see on our
public rankings page here.
It's a single API that you pay for once.
you get near zero switching costs to go
from model to model. Uh and we have
about 400 over 400 models over 60 active
providers and uh you can buy with lots
of different payment methods including
crypto and and we basically do all the
the tricky work of normalizing tool
calls and caching for you so that you
get the best prices and the most
features uh and you don't have to worry
about what the provider supports.
Another story. Initially, open router
was not a marketplace really. It was
just kind of a collection of all the
models and a way to explore data about
who was using each one. So, how did we
get here?
Initially, when the first open source
models emerged, uh we only had like one
or two providers for each one. And so,
we had like a primary provider and a
fallback provider. And initially that
was it. And and we didn't even name the
providers. Um, but it became clear that
there were going to be a bunch of
companies that wanted to host these prov
these models and at very different
prices and performances.
The number of features ballooned. Um,
there were companies that supported the
minp sampler and most didn't. There were
some that supported caching, some that
supported tool calling and structured
outputs and others that didn't. And
suddenly the ecosystem was just
ballooning into this kind of
outofcontrol heterogeneous
monster and we wanted to tame the
monster. So we aggregated all providers
in one spot and at different price
points it became a marketplace and you
can see like this model Llama 3.370B
instruct um has one one of the models
with the most providers on the platform
um and it has like 23
um closed source models also had
something interesting happened to them
which is that they just they couldn't
keep up with the demand and uh and and
so We help developers basically get
uptime boosting and you can see like the
delta uh and how much we can boost
uptime just by aggregating lots of
different providers for a model and this
became really helpful for people using
open source or closed source and we
became a marketplace for both um showing
graphs about latency and throughput and
helping people figure out using real
world data what the latency and
throughput is on each model.
Um and that's how open router became a
marketplace and a one optimized for
language models which I thought would be
proper for for inference potentially the
biggest market in software.
Uh you can obviously a couple other
things that we support comparing models
we using your own prompts with the ease
of just texting and iMessage. um fine
grain privacy controls with API level
overrides, the ability to see like your
usage of all models in one place and
have great observability.
And back to the original question here
of whether will intelligence be winner
or take all. Uh I I we've come to the
most likely bet that that is not the
case. Um here's our data broken down by
model author. um how much how many
tokens have been processed by each one.
And you can see Google Gemini started
pretty low like roughly two 3% in June
of last year and just has grown to 34
35%
uh pretty steadily over the last 12
months. Um uh Enthropic
uh is is like one of the most popular
models on our platform. Open AAI is a
little bit under reppresented in this
data um because a lot of developers use
us to get open AI like behavior for all
of their models. But OpenAI as has grown
a lot here as well.
So
here's what we believe about the market
after all of the
you know backstory that I just gave you.
Um the future is going to be multimodel.
Ton all of our customers, tons of
customers use different models for
different purposes and realize they can
unlock huge gains by doing so. Inference
is also a commodity. Claude from bedrock
we want to make look exactly the same as
Cloud from Vert.ex. And we do that
because like the two hyperscalers have
fundamentally uh you know the same
commodity being delivered at different
rates, different performances and for a
developer you just want to be able to
like select that without worrying about
who's serving it. Um we think inference
will be like a dominant operating
expense and selecting and routing will
be crucial. Um you can see the number of
active models on open router has just
steadily grown. It's not the case that
people just hop from model to model.
Like it tends to be sticky and uh and we
tr we're trying to just make this wild
ecosystem a lot more homogeneous and
easier to work with as a developer.
Um to honor Swix's title for this
presentation, uh let's give a technical
story. um something that we worked on in
the process of building the company and
that was our own idea for how to do an
MCP within open router. So we don't have
MCPS, we don't have an MCP marketplace.
Um but we did run into the need to
expand inference with new features and
new abilities. for example, searching
the web for all models, PDF parsing for
all models. Um, you know, other
interesting things coming soon. And what
we really wanted to do was give these
abilities to all models. But that
involves not just the pre-flight work
that MCPs do today where you can kind of
get in like call another API, get a
bunch of behaviors and then have the
inference process access those behaviors
as it goes. We also needed the ability
to transform the outputs on the way to
the user. And so what we really really
needed was something more like
middleware. Middleware um is kind of a
common concept in web development. You
set up middleware when you're setting up
authentication for example or or or
caching for a web app. And so we came up
with a type of middleware that's sort of
that's AI native and optimized for
inference. Um and that looks not totally
dissimilar from the way middleware it
looks in in Nex.js JS or web
development. Yeah. So, pardon the code
on the screen, but this is a little bit
about how our our plug-in system looks
and it, you know, it can call MCPS from
inside a plugin, but importantly, it can
also augment the results on the way back
to the user. So, here's an example of
our web search plugin, which augments
every language model with the ability to
search the web. um every language model
can just kind of tap in to this plugin
and get web annotations as results are
being fed back to users in real time.
And this all happens in a stream. So
there's no kind of like you know
requirement that you get all of the
tokens at once. It can just happen in
live in the stream.
We we solved a bunch of other tricky
problems
uh while building open router. We we
really wanted to get extremely low
latency. Um and we got it down to about
30 milliseconds uh the best in the
industry I believe. Um using a lot of
custom cache work and we also need to
make streams canceable. All these
different providers have completely
different stream cancellation policies.
Sometimes if you just drop a stream the
the the the inference provider will bill
you for the entire thing. Sometimes it
won't. Sometimes it'll bill you for the
next 20 tokens that you never got. And
um we kind we we work a lot to try to
figure out these edge cases and
understand when developers are going to
care about them too. And standardizing
all these providers and models uh became
like a big tricky architecture problem
that we spent a while working on. So
here's where all this is going. Uh we're
going to add more modalities to open
router and I think this is like a big
change in the industry as well. We're
going to start seeing LLMs generate
images. We already have uh a few
examples on the market, but like some
people call it transfusion models, a
transformer mixed with stable diffusion.
Um these are going to give images way
more world knowledge and the ability to
have a conversation with the image,
which we think is just critical for
growing that industry, making it really
work. Imagine I just ran into somebody
today who is using a transfusion model
uh or who told me about their customer
using a transfusion model to generate
menus. Imagine doing that like a whole
menu like in a delivery app generated by
transfusion model. Um it's going to be
really exciting and and a big deal in
the coming year.
We're also going to work on much more
powerful routing like routing is our
bread and butter and so doing
geographical routing. Right now we it's
pretty minimal but routing people to the
right GPU in the right place and doing
enterprise level optimization is coming
um better prompt observability better
discovery of models like really fine
grain categorization you know imagine
being able to see like the best models
that take Japanese and and create Python
code
and of course even better prices coming
soon. So, you know, we we believe in in
collaboration um and and building an
ecosystem that's durable and with low
vendor lock in. So, you know,
collaborate with us. Um here's our email
and if you're interested, join us, too.
[Music]